ça pique un majeur à l'agenda des mavs
et jacques gamblin nombreux dit
désormais s'attendre et qui s'encrasse
de rasoir si un peu difficile que je
vais faire attention je vais partir dans
une île je parle adhésives soldats le
long de la rivière elle bossait sommes
collés
la silhouette les chairs aussi fan de
fulham flair est né dans une lumière qui
passe comme un propos laissent enfin
mexicaine bien sûr mariama lui disais
souvent des gens pour le prix demandé à
des juristes foulée avec des poulets
avec les cochons se payer vos ébats
sociale et le vent mou du calcio à
quelques participants
ça ne s'est pas dit surpris d'une telle
dallas échographie couple il va la
placer sous le nom de la rivière le
fusil en bandoulière débouchant de la
clairière est venu le pomper de l'eau
et ça donne depuis des mois je l'espère
depuis des mois qui m'est chère ne
traitez pas sa colère mon coeur est à 0
à 0 sur ajoie mexicaine avec hubert
minnis était trop c'est pas grave on
l'est tous les chemins mènent au talent
de l'écrasante et j'ai fais ton plus
qu'autre chose et non un homme si sarah
connor
ici tout le long de la rivière
j'ai développé taxe minière et la glace
les cacher dans les fougères
j'ai bien regardé passer
depuis des mois j'ai des spurs depuis
des mois du mai cher
les paupières
très bien
jarry français alors normalement d'après
les prévisions là je devrais être prêt
mais alors on n'est pas tout à fait prêt
à payer on va faire le coeur mo
à mes yeux la mesure à mesure en ayez où
on n'est pas en ayez faite en mesurer la
tension
j'ai tant prisée thème un mois
alors alors alors c'est pas fini à
l'heure dans la coulisse maison marie et
marie quant au lait s'est envolé
alors j'ai pas ensemble des pasdaran aia